Adam Vinatieri the Colts kicker is
within 35 field goals 166 points of
passing Morten Andersen for both records
all-time list I believe one for one as a
quarterback as well and it was a
touchdown Adam Vinatieri the Colts
kicker future hall-of-famer joins us
what do you remember about that
touchdown pass well thank goodness for
me that is an uncovered kind of a
hideout fake field goal situation so I
guess for me you know I kept that's a
difficulty stated and you just have to
make an easy pass maybe that makes it
more difficult but thank goodness I was
on line four on product steps into the
end zone and when I got the rest of this
through my quarterback or anything is
better than most of this both of the
Gunners out there so it's a good thing
do you remember the last time you
thought your job was in jeopardy I feel
like my job is in jeopardy every single
week and maybe that's what keeps me
motivated and keeps me moving in the
right direction
there's a million kids out there that
would like to have my job and there's
only 32 positions out there so I go to
work every day assuming that if I don't
do my job well though I'll find a way to
replace me with somebody else so even if
there's not anybody in camp or in the in
the and the meeting room or during the
season if I'm the only kicker on the
team that doesn't mean that they're
there a phone call away so that's the
way I always look at it I try to go to
work every day and do the best I can and
hopefully the consistency of doing a
good job around a little longer but you
came is signed as a free agent and I'm
wondering if the expectation level at
that position we saw Sebastian
Janikowski as the first-round draft pick
and he's lived up to that billing but
then you just sold Tampa Bay get rid of
Roberto Aguayo second-round pick so it
how different is that to come in as a
undrafted kicker as opposed to hey we
actually went up in the draft to get you
as a second-round draft pick adding even
more pressure to that position how does
that affect you well you're right you
know you might have a little more
pressure if you're a high draft choice I
think everybody probably expects you to
come out and do well right from the
get-go but our positions a little
different I don't think there's a whole
lot of
growing time involved with us I said I
think if you're a your safety or a
quarterback or this or that they kind of
expect you to learn the system for a
year or two and and you know kind of
kind of doing you into that I think as a
phoner ticker they expect you to do a
good job right away and if not there's
there's a long list of people that they
can call their to do that so I I
wouldn't know what it feels like to be
drafted first or second round I never
was so I can't speak on that side but I
still feel like as an undrafted you know
free agent my rookie year I felt like
they didn't have anything invested in me
so I didn't do a good job you really
easy to replace me and find somebody
else so I think that leaks built on
plenty of pressure no matter your Hydra
to if you're a free agent I think
they're always looking to find the best
player and the best guy at a certain
position and sometimes it's hey this
guy's cheaper than that guy and maybe
save some salary cap room but I think at
the end of the day most teams want the
best guy at whatever position and then
they have to figure out you know how to
make it work in the salary cap but fresh
kickers I don't think even even if
you're the lowest guy on the celery list
or the highest kicker in the league our
money doesn't really affect the salary
cap too terribly much so I think I think
they try to go get the best player you
know that they can and hope that this
person puts a lot of points and makes a
lot of scores and makes a lot of kicks
that help their team win games he's had
embedded cherry the Colts kicker joining
us Dan Patrick show we had this a debate
yesterday would you rather be a starting
place kicker a Pro Bowl place kicker or
a backup quarterback in the NFL for your
career I would definitely say kicker I
want to be I want to be on the field I
don't know about having my head on
backward and a bag of confident old the
clipboard no disrespect to any of those
guys it's probably a great position but
there's something about being on the
field and helping my team win games you
know for me now if it was being a being
a kicker or being the starting
quarterback now I got a sense about that
one a little bit because that's a that's
a pretty awesome role to be in if you're
if you're good enough to do it did you
take it personally when your days with
the Patriots were over
like that they they moved on or they you
know I know it's business but you know
you're all that everything you did for
that team and you you win Super Bowls
and playoff games and how can you not
take it personally I think the older I
get and the more removed from it I get
the more I realized business business um
you know I felt at the time that I still
had some good years left and wanted to
make sure that that they thought I went
through a couple of one year you know
franchise tag things and I just wanted a
little bit more show me a little love
and explain that I could be around for a
while and and so that I think that was
the underlining thing that kind of kept
us from from moving to moving on
together but you know I look back at I
have all the love in the world narration
for for that staff he owner Robert Kraft
Bill Belichick and and the whole staff
and the players I mean I still have a
lot of friends that played on well only
uh only one or two now they're not he'll
on the team but a lot of guys that have
moved on and retired that that these
guys are my brothers just like anybody
else my real family or or or guys here
at the quotes I mean I it's pretty neat
fraternity being on teams that have won
Super Bowls together so no matter where
I'm at wherever I go I still have a lot
of admiration for that organization do
you think Brady retires a patriot I
would I would assume that will be the
case yeah but he would be the one to
survive because you know you've gotten
rid of Pro Bowl deep you know Thai law
and lawyer Milloy
and run down the list there that you
know class guys who didn't last there
but do you think Brady is the anomaly
that they have to keep him in a patriot
uniform for as long as he wants to play
well I look at it this way he's not
showing any any signs of slowing down
anytime soon I mean a guy keeps on just
having you know amazing year after
amazing year keeps on you know stats
after stats I mean I know I know coach
Belichick and that staff is the type of
people that if that changed you know
they're probably not afraid of moving in
a different direction but I don't see I
don't see coming back and down anytime
soon he just he just keeps on doing
amazing things and
and that organization extraordinary they
lucky to have a to have him as their as
their quarterback running that team for
as long as they have who plays longer
you or Tom Brady you know I don't know
how many more he still looks like you
could play another ten years I'm not
sure how many four he wants I think I
think I got a couple years on him on the
front end so I'm hoping I can get a
couple more years so that would that
means he's got to play at least another
five or six so we'll see we'll see what
he can do see how many more I got but I
don't have any any wants to settle down
or retire anytime soon either so no
matter how many he's got he's got to you
got to keep going a few more Intel I'm
done if you had a passing contest right
now you against Andrew Luck who's
winning Andrew probably I haven't been
watching his stuff but I'm not by any
means I'm not as good as is the NFL
quarterback out there no matter if
they're coming off of injuries and we
had a bad guy I think he's probably
better left handed in and I would ever
be right handed Adam Congrats on the
success so far and a good luck this
upcoming season thanks for joining us my
pleasure thanks for Adam and Adam
Vinatieri the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience